So one thing I'd like to show you in the browser
is we're going to go to Reddit and we're go to reddit.json. So
this is going to load Reddit's front page expressed in JSON, which is
something we've implemented on Reddit so computers can, you know, browse Reddit
and people can write third party software that uses Reddit. And
so when you add .json to Reddit, you get this wall of
text, which brings us to our next quiz. Okay, in this quiz,
what I've done for you is I have a variable called reddit_front,
which is what I just showed you from the browser, it's reddit
frontpage expressed in json. Now this is actually quite a lot of
bit of data look at my scroll bar it's a very long
line, you not to worry too much about that. Just know that it
is a string json string of Reddit's front page. Now, what I'd
like you to do, use the JSON library to parse this string, find
in there the links. It's kind of a deep data structure. You
can copy and paste this into, you know, a Python editor if it
makes it a little bit easier. You need to find the links,
and each link has an ups attribute. And what I want you to
do is write a function called total_ups which returns the total number
of ups, you know, the sum of all of the ups of all
of the links in this list. Now, there isn't anything else in
this list that has ups. So basically, if you can find every instance
of the key-value pair ups and value, add them all up, and return
it. I just want to test your ability to load this JSON and
manipulate it a little bit. Okay, good luck.